okay everybody in our first story paul
tudor jones was on cnbc squawk box this
morning talking about inflation and
bitcoin uh ptj if you don't know is a
hedge fund manager he's another
billionaire um and he runs something
called tudor investment corporation they
have 44 billion dollars in assets under
management
that's the old aum if you ever hear that
term aum assets under management it's
not your money necessarily but that's
how much money that you are the steward
of so when you hear you know chamoth or
saks or i have a certain number of
assets under management that's like how
much money we've put to work and
generally speaking people get a
percentage of the gain on that money so
if he has 44 billion dollars and it goes
up he probably gets 20 of the gain hedge
funds get paid a little differently than
venture funds uh so he founded his fund
back in 1980 and he's known for
predicting uh the 1987 stock market
crash and cashing in with a lot of short
positions um his short positions back
then resulted in 100 million dollars in
profit according to a profile in finance
monthly so he's generally super credible
and an interesting character there was a
crazy documentary made about him in the
80s
that he and his company have spent a lot
of time trying to take down the dock was
titled traitor what an inspired name
so ptj talked with uh
ars andra sorkin wednesday uh on squawk
box first up here's a 47 second clip of
ptj giving his current thoughts on
inflation very similar to the discussion
we've been having on the all-in podcast
specifically uh episode 51 i talked a
little bit about the number of jobs that
were available
and the number of people who were not
taking them and who were opting out of
being in the workforce i saw that as a
very specific issue in the economy
i called it indigestion and
uh ptj has similar thoughts let's play
the clip and i'll talk to you in 47
seconds
and it's pretty clear to me that
inflation is not transitory it's here to
stay and it's probably the single
biggest threat
to certainly financial markets and again
probably i think to society just in
general so
this 5.4
cpi is a real eye opener it's a high cpi
we've had in 30 years and of course it's
going to go higher here in the next few
months as energy feeds through it so
for an investor in particular most of
this audience it's
absolute death for a 60 40 portfolio for
a long stock long bond portfolio so the
real question is how do you defend
yourself against it how persistent will
this be
and um what is the outlook hole
all right so if you don't know what the
cpi is that's the consumer price index
it's a measure of the average change
over time in the prices paid by urban
consumers for a market basket of
consumer goods and services that's
obviously been going up think food uh
energy gas in your car you know staples
that kind of stuff and it rose five
point four percent uh from september to
september that's obviously a big deal
and inflation uh i was reading up on 70
in the 70s there was obviously massive
inflation
and the inflation was like seven percent
i think on average there were a couple
years when it was 12 percent that
obviously can cause problems for uh you
know people in the working class who
have to buy milk and gas and uh puts a
little pressure on them but that
pressure obviously means you got to go
to work so perhaps there is something
happening here where
you know this will drive some people to
take all the open jobs and maybe get off
the sidelines because they need some
money but we pumped a lot of money into
the system and this is causing the
indigestion then ptj
broke down why he believes inflation is
not transitory and this transitory
debate
you know uh is a big one because if this
keeps going if you know the rule of 72
this means if you take any number of
time periods uh and you divide it into
72 that's how long it takes to double so
in other words
if you were growing 10 percent year over
year in inflation in seven years the
cost of 7.2 years the cost of goods
would double conversely if you were
growing 36 a year in inflation which
would be kind of impossible but if
bitcoin was going up 36 a year it would
double every two years right you're
dividing 36 into 72 that's the number of
time periods you can do it for days
weeks months whatever years
and so
if it's not transitory it's going to be
compounding and that means every 10
years the cost of
jeans or you know your car or the gas
you're putting in your car is gonna
double is your salary doubling in that
same period of time well if salaries are
growing four percent on average and
uh let's say you know consumer goods are
growing at seven percent or homes are
growing at twelve percent you have this
delta you have this gap between what
people are making what they can afford
and that obviously can cause a lot of um
pain and suffering uh
in an economy so i'll talk to you after
this one minute and 45 second clip
there's a combination
of structural and cyclical forces
that right now are all rolling in the
same direction
to say that inflation can be
much worse than what we fear so let's
just start with the cyclical forces
first we have the demand side of the
equation and that would be
m2 m2 has grown 5.4 trillion since the
pandemic began that's three and a half
trillion dollars
greater than what it normally would have
that three and a half trillion sixteen
percent of gdp
just sitting in liquid deposits that
could go into stocks or crypto or real
estate or be consumed so that's a huge
amount of dry powder that's just sitting
there
waiting to be utilized at some point
which is why inflation's not
going to be transitory another demand
factor would be we just raised benefits
for social security retirees as well as
military about 75 million by 5.9 percent
that's just more fuel right to the
inflationary fire
the second big component
would be the wage pressure that we've
got
and the easiest way to see that is
obviously
job offers relatively unemployed we're
10.4 million job offers 7.7 million
unemployed it's clear that we have a
structural issue in our labor force
that's not going to be solved by
zero percent interest rates and
quantitative easing the structural
issues are first and foremost we have a
federal reserve board
that are inflation creators right not
flag inflation fighters
all right so there you have it folks uh
if you don't know m2 money supply m1 is
like cash in your bank account m2 is
stuff that you can convert into money so
a money market account mutual fund etf
etc so they like to put these m1 and m2s
together i guess economists and finance
folks
and his point is you could get that
money and then go buy something with it
that's not you know the 60 40 portfolio
of stocks and bonds that people would
normally do obviously crypto could be
part of that or gold or a home etc and
people have a lot of money and if they
have a lot of money and they don't go to
work
the money's sitting there inflation is
happening well the money becomes worth
less so
if you had
i don't know let's just pick uh three
thousand dollars in cash in your bank
account and gas was three dollars a
gallon now you can afford a thousand uh
gallons of gasoline
okay now it goes up to six dollars so
now you can afford 500 gallons of
gasoline nothing's happened but your
money goes
uh doesn't go uh as far in terms of
buying food or buying gas or buying
clothes
and um he points out you know the the
job conundrum that we have right now
jobs are especially entry-level jobs or
you know starting your career jobs or
flex jobs
that were you know
minimum wage seven eight bucks all the
way up to 12 bucks are now 18 to 35
a lot of them didn't have benefits now
they have some amount of benefits or
even full benefits some of them are
coming over the top with will pay for
your associate's degree like amazon
or starbucks i mean people are really
putting a lot of pot sweeteners out
there to get people off the sidelines
and i think this m2 issue just tons of
monetary supply
is what's causing the problem
listen right now linkedin is gonna give
you a hundred dollar credit towards your
first ad campaign i kid you not go to
linkedin.com
checklist and get that hundy right now
because it's not to last forever
linkedin.com
checklist to get the hyundai you need
high quality leads you know that your
team is asking you please get us those
great leads every startup founder and
marketer has been there you're planning
to launch that new campaign you know who
your audience is your team is happy and
everything's going according to plan
maybe even love the creative except that
one thought in the back of your head how
can i be sure that my acquisition
campaign will drive high impact leads
for my sales team well with linkedin ads
you don't need to guess because when you
advertise on linkedin your messages
reach people who are ready to engage on
linkedin there are over 30 million
companies engaging and over 71 percent
of professionals are using linkedin to
inform their business decisions that's
why linkedin can help bring your growth
to the next level linkedin equals
business business equals linkedin it
really is that simple we all know it's
true so here's your cta the old call to
action do business where business is
done and get a 100 ad credit put your
first linkedin campaign at linkedin.com
checklist verbs and conditions do apply
because they're giving you a hundy